oh that's a good chin it's a good chin
can I touch it
no-one's ever let me do that before
weird oh got stubble in everything I'm
not gonna mess with you you are 50%
tattoo is that correct what's what's
your favorite tattoo the one she did oh
my gosh what is it her signature oh
that's nice you can never break up now
that's that's please don't break up my
my grandfather had Dorothy tattooed on
his arm Dorothy was not his wife's name
and he would always tell a lie he'd be
like oh yeah it was it was a dog I loved
very much yeah sure oh that's that's
nice that you do you have a tattoo do
you have his signature on you no no I
have no tattoos I I am scared of them
and people with them as well if I want
one of those little tears on your face
they give you I feel like I should have
one I'm pretty pretty badass I am I'm a
pretty badass rapper a lot of people
don't know that in the UK I'm the best
rapper in England which it's not hard
obviously it's true I like a lot I like
rap I like um I like making up raps
freestyle rap that's you know it's a rap
it's not written down it's entirely
improvised in the moment so like let's
let's just give it a go let's get some
yeah yeah I'm not joking it's happening
you have that please lay not be
happening it's happening
I'm gonna take some suggestions I think
think of a word or a topic or a phrase I
don't take boring suggestions and I'll
tell you if they're boring if it's a
food or an animal it's probably boring
if it's like Trump or brexit it's boring
okay I don't take the same suggestions
twice I'm gonna make an executive
decision the first suggestion will be
getting a signature as a tattoo cuz I
like that and also I do want to keep you
on side because you might hang around
afterwards and punch me so we'll take
four more suggestions so that's one for
each quarter of the room if you're in
this segment here what would you guys
want to hear a rap about gonorrhea now
the the comedy magic club in Hermosa
Beach is famed for being pretty much
quite a clean comedy venue and it feels
quite early in the show to take such a
virulent ly dangerous sexually
transmitted disease and as my mother
always told me Chris steer clear of
gonorrhea so she was a rapper as well
everything she said rhymes um your mum I
love you son she was great so if I'm
honest with you gonorrhea has been
suggested here many times before I never
take the same situation twice so I'm not
gonna take that but let's go for a
second go what's it gonna be bipolar
disorder I wish I'd taken goner in that
bipolar disorder getting a signature as
the tattoo middle this side what you
guys want to rap about Wow - at the same
time you said cocaine you said British
food I will combine those together
cocaine being the only type of British
food bipolar disorder getting a
signature as a tattoo this segment here
let's go for it no Chris we're too
scared you okay
you're not from that section
but I also like that I came to this
actually could it said it them but it
took a while for you to get it out which
feels perfect for that I mean use you
said the wall as well didn't you which
again both of those things are kind of a
builder um its cleverer than you thought
it was constipation bipolar disorder
getting a signature as a tattoo and what
was this one section cocaine is British
food and let this this section here you
guys have been being really well-behaved
and quiet so what's what's it gonna be
what's you suggest the best suggestion
anyone ever said ninth-century crop
rotation let's try and fight in that
league there's some debate going down
here you've got glasses on you look
smart
I am this the Industrial Revolution okay
it's pretty it's a pretty broad topic
now what would you like to focus on
would you like to focus on maybe you
know like Telford is the birthplace the
initial revolution or Manchester is the
cradle of it or the the iron bridge
across the eye bridge gorge or did you
just say it and hope I didn't go into
such depth and detail I went up but I've
said those now so it feels a little bit
like a trick
Wow it's it's rare that you asked for a
suggestion and get a dissertation thesis
the emergence of early factory of the
emergence of factory retail in the early
Industrial Revolution don't worry I
don't know what half those words mean so
the suggestions we have are cocaine as
British food getting a signature as a
tattoo the emergence of factory retail
in the early Industrial Revolution
oh gosh these are too many suggestions
and the other two were bipolar disorder
and constipation right I'm gonna chat
charge you with remembering these you're
welcome you're welcome I like you this
then lovely people a freestyle rap a rap
made up on the spot based entirely on
those suggestions nothing is written
nothing's rehearsed and do not worry
we'll not be anywhere near as
atrociously bad as you're expecting a 29
you're all privately educated middle
class why English boy to be may we roll
that beat let's see how we do and you
can
[Music]
obviously is got piano in guys
I'm partial bridge
[Music]
it's gonna be fun make it up as I go no
idea what I do I'm sitting on the loo
you know I'm straining for a poo a
Turner taking some Seneca to loosen my
bowels it's so hard to push out you're a
clench my jowls and how when I try and
push it down my intestine I really need
some more creams to be ingested that's
the suggestion from my mother room
father's secrets every time you run the
loo for half an hour sitting up there on
the porcelain frog I never go for booze
in public only comfort on my home cuz it
takes too long I'll say it again like a
hard equation I work it out with a pen I
just start jiggling around and loosen
their edges so cool with the stool yeah
I'm sitting like a Ledge it's so damn
amazing I feel the trapdoor pain and so
alleviate it with a bit of cocaine a
cram just a smidge in the only drug in a
British kitchen you open up the fridge
you looking for food and all you find
inside the white goods another white
good got it in the little ziplock bag
you see the buy-in from the deal around
the street is not a tragedy people think
the British food tastes so awful
now it's amazing when you put it up your
nostril that is up there I don't care
all the hair blocking all the powder
from Columbia I would rather I could get
it locally not far away but all mine is
imported from Bogota so hey anyway the
next thing I or the knot of cocaine
start of bipolar disorder you might say
frisk I wanna impress this you can call
it BPD or manic depressive either way it
doesn't matter which one you got I read
the manual that you doctor has scrawled
all over maybe is it
DMS for I don't even know I've never
looked about that before if you're
suddenly happy and then you're suddenly
down in the dumps you probably a manic
depression town my favorite British guy
you've got it
it's Stephen Fry why does it happen in
the brain nobody knows why maybe
serotonin is lacking and you feel the
black dog that's the symbol of
depression here it leaves like a frog on
your back you try and escape but you
can't just do it if you suffering from
depression fight through it it will be
okay
yeah that's what I did I feel depressed
in the past I'm a [ __ ] faced kid
working in a factory saying I feel
forgotten who all I'm doing here is the
manufacturing cotton and the fabric
itself
my mom is over here
I don't wash no ablutions I'm the victim
of the Industrial Revolution that's what
I do I'm just a kid one day I might get
a tattoo I'll ask you what's the best
one that I should get and you would say
oh yeah listen up pet you need to get
this now make sure you pick the right
one
the wife lady that I've mean because the
signature on your ankle will be amply
adored but the problem is you could
commit identity fraud there you go
[Applause]
it was alright
[Applause]